my name's alan bernstein and i've had
the
distinct pleasure and honor of being
president and ceo of cfar for the last
10 years plus
so i'd like to begin with a
you're not supposed to applaud then by
the way
um
i'd like to begin with a land
acknowledgement
uh um
we are of course holding this meeting
in uh
uh and 40 years of sea forest
headquarters
have been on the traditional territory
of many nations including the
mississauga of the credit
the addition of it the chippewa the
nanashini the wendat peoples and is now
home to many diverse nations
inuit and metis peoples
we also acknowledge that toronto is
covered by treaty 13 with the
mississaugas of the credit
now good afternoon everybody i should
also say good morning and good evening
because there's people online from
around the world i'm thrilled
to see so many uh meet members of the
cfar community friends
of the seafarer community staff
fellows global scholars supporters and
board members here today some of our
board members have actually never met
each other you know in 3d so it's really
really quite remarkable actually
this is one of cfar's very first
in-person events since march 2020. i
mean think about that's remember that
month
and it's for a really important occasion
happy occasion our 40th
not my 40th but see first 40th
on behalf of all of us at c4 i would
like to thank you for joining us today
i would also like to thank the more than
100 people who are apparently online
listening to this
i also want to give a particularly warm
welcome
to the representatives from those
companies who have been with us almost
from our very beginning
uh mda which in those days was spar
aerospace
keller wines
rbc and manulife
[Applause]
you know was founded on a remarkably
simple idea
uh
first
that science and research are simply the
best way humanity has come up with to
understand the world around us
second
that the world needs new ideas to
address the many problems increasingly
many problems
that humanity faces
and third
that the best scientists from around the
world are actually eager to work
together to take on complex high risk
challenges
that have solved will increase the
well-being of all people
no organization on the planet does what
we do
which is to bring together some of the
world's best scholars and scientists to
address questions of importance to
science and to humanity
and we do it in a unique way going back
to our roots 40 years ago and continuing
to today
we are canadian-based but international
we are problem-based
not discipline based and since our
inception we have valued diversity of
perspective and we only tackle high-risk
complex questions
the proof
is in the pudding of course
have we turned the impossible
into the possible
here's a partial list
our fellows way back brilliantly
assembled both existing and new evidence
demonstrating that health and disease
are largely governed by the
socio-economic determinants of health
highlighted the importance of the early
years in a child's trajectory of mental
physical and and social development
developed the snowball earth hypothesis
to explain
to explain some of the earliest events
in the evolution of our planet
elucidated all the genetic networks that
underlie the behavior of a living cell
pioneered important areas in quantum
physics and astrophysics
and i have to say astrophysics dick bond
is here
including breakthroughs in
superconductivity
major advances in quantum computing and
discovered a mysterious new set of
objects in our universe called fast
radio bursts
and put forward some of the very first
evidence for the role of science and
innovation in driving economic growth
and broke the log jam and artificial
intelligence by pioneering the
development of deep learning
and along the way unleashed
trillions literally trillions of dollars
of private sector investment in this new
technology and i have left out many
recent advances in brain development
consciousness the microbiome we'll hear
more from the about the fungal kingdom
shortly
and the reshaping of our planet
the key to our success i believe is
quite simple
it's our people
our fellows and global scholars are
quite simply some of the best scientists
and scholars on the planet
their contributions to to knowledge
are acknowledged with the world's most
prestigious international awards and
prizes from 20 nobel prizes
to the touring prize the nobel of
mathematics to hundreds of other
prestigious awards
every year
our fellows are cited more often per
person than any group of scientists or
universities anywhere
it is truly a remarkable record of
excellence
our people also include an amazing staff
who are the most dedicated committed and
capable people that have i i have had
the honor of working with and i've
worked with a lot of staff i can't hold
a job since
our advisors from the advisory boards
attached to our 12 programs
to the international science advisory
council that adjudicates the canada c4ai
chairs program
to the jury that chooses each
intake of canada's as cfar as reality
global scholars
and to the president's advisory council
who advised me and cfar's executive on
high levels of policy and program
development
and finally cfar's board of directors
many of whom are here
tonight
is made up of exceptional women and men
who care deeply for this organization
no president and i mean this quite
sincerely could ask for a stronger or
more committed board
finally
our supporters are an exceptional group
of individuals and organizations
i i actually totally understand why
people support their alma mater the arts
and charities that supports
disease-related
science
but to support an organization whose
only commitment
is to excellence in science with no
promise
of necessarily changing the world
can only be done by special people who
get it
they understand that truly changing the
world is best done by the best people
who by working together can turn the
impossible into the possible
that takes patience it takes time and it
takes confidence in the organization
that one chooses to support
and for that all of us at cfar are very
very truly grateful thank you very very
much
your your support
has enabled our fellows and global
scholars to be bold
to tackle high-risk questions and as a
result to make an impact on the world
in 1982
40 years ago if you've done your math
cfar began as just a tiny organization
with barely a handful of canadian
scientists
today cfar has emerged as the world's
research organization
over the last four decades more than a
thousand researchers from over 30
countries have been part of our research
programs as fellows advisors canada cfr
ai chairs and cefar asrieli global
scholars
now no organization can stand still
the world is changing too rapidly and
too profoundly to think that what is
relevant today will continue to be
relevant tomorrow
and so over the past decade we have not
stood still
first we have launched our global call
for ideas an entirely new way of
soliciting ideas and people to launch
new cfar programs
through our first two global calls we
have rebuilt our portfolio of global
research programs
we are now in the middle of our third
global call for ideas really ably
overseen by our vp research dr mark daly
who's somewhere here there he is
second with a generous support of the
israeli foundation
and i'm so pleased to welcome all the
members of the israeli board to this
event today
they've come all the way from israel to
come to this event
we launched the cfair azraeli global
scholars program and we've just
announced
our seventh intake of 18
truly remarkable young investigators
from around the world
third at the request of the government
of canada we developed and launched in
2017 the world's first national ai
strategy the pan-canadian ai strategy
that strategy was just renewed in the
last federal budget
and has grown and has grown from its
original 125 million over five years
to almost 500 million over the next five
years
as a partnership between
cfar
the three ai institutes miele vector and
amy and the government of canada
and finally our fellows
have enthusiastically shared their
knowledge with the world
engaging with more than three thousand
policy makers in canada and
internationally with parents and
educators with industry with the
development of developers of medical
school curricula and with people
interested to know more about the
planets beneath their feet
and the cosmos far beyond the earth's
atmosphere
ten years ago i became cfart's president
succeeding having hoseok after her
eleven great years at the helm
it is a real pleasure for me to see
khabib here today
and to recognize her many contributions
that she led
at sifart during her tenure aviva
i'm also very pleased
that coming this fall i would i will be
passing the baton in my turn to stephen
tupe currently the vice chancellor or
president of cambridge university
and former president of the university
of british columbia when he takes over
as cephar's fifth
president
this is to paraphrase charles dickens
the best of times and the worst of times
it is a time of great on heap upheaval
and uncertainty from the coveted
pandemic the climate change to the
invasion of the ukraine to the rise of
populism to the closing of doors between
the west and china
it is also though a time of truly
remarkable progress in science
a vaccine against a new virus in less
than a year it's unbelievable the ligo
experiment that validated einstein's
prediction of 1905 that gravitational
waves exist
crispr technology to introduce
exquisitely subtle modifications into
the human genome to cure disease
and the application of a.i
to everything
this progress in science will continue
and indeed it will accelerate and see
fire will continue
to turn the impossible
into the possible
so let's see our new video to show that
robot arms in space
fungus that breaks down pollution
[Music]
knowing the root of happiness
much of what we know today was once
thought to be impossible
unreachable feats that stretch the
imagination
but what transforms the impossible
to possible
knowledge it's 1.4 billion years of data
research
pushing the frontiers of science to make
ideas for the greater good of the world
real
at cfar that's what we're able to do
building inclusive nations is necessary
to convene the brightest minds from
around the world from every discipline
the neural oscillations in your brain to
challenge the status quo that will take
ai to the next step to pursue high-risk
ideas they are a new type of machine to
allow borderless research to bring to
life what many thought could not exist
and you can actually see the chemistry
new ideas that enhance the everyday
new ideas that enhance our understanding
of the world we are now at the dawn of a
new age
new ideas that improve humanity it has
gotten quite a bit of attention
so
understand why we champion
world-renowned researchers and nurture
the next generation of talent to defy
the impossible that suggests to us that
there are legacies of trauma that start
off in one generation and then
perpetuate across generations
because global excellence be it the 20
nobel prizes in 40 years or the 1700
major awards it all comes from
understanding that anything can be
together
we build a possible future
cfar
believe the impossible
learn more at
cfar.ca
40.
[Applause]
before i introduce the moderator of
today's panel discussion i would like to
take a moment to thank the amazing
members of cfar staff who have been
leading the planning for our 40th
thank you for your commitment and
passion for your hard work in organizing
today's public launch event and for the
many for the celebration events that lie
ahead this year it's a long list so
instead of calling out everyone's names
i apologize for that could everyone
please wave who's on the staff committee
[Applause]
i would now like to introduce dr naomi
israeli
chair and ceo of the israeli foundation
who will moderate this afternoon's
exciting panel discussion
when i talk about cfar's trajectory a
big part of our future success has a lot
to do with the next generation of
researchers
so i had the distinct pleasure of
sharing our vision for the global
scholars program with naomi in 2016
2016. that vision was shared
enthusiastically and i must say
immediately by naomi and then by the
asrieli board as a result of their
support
we have now selected well over a hundred
of the world's top young people over the
past seven years to become asrieli
global scholars
including the 18 we just announced last
week
if ever you're feeling down about the
state of the world i have the perfect
prescription for you
just talk to any of our global scholars
for
30 minutes i guarantee
you will walk away with a lighter step
a smile on your face and a new
confidence in the future
this unique and important program would
not exist if it weren't for the
visionary generosity of the azraeli
foundation led by naomi
it is now my distinct pleasure to
welcome naomi ezrieli who will moderate
our panel
discussion ladies and gentlemen dr naomi
estrielli
thank you very much alan
hello good afternoon everyone it's a
great pleasure to be here
to look out to some familiar faces and
some people i've been hearing about and
i look forward to talking to more
following the panel
it's really a delight to be here along
with as alan mentioned many members of
my board and some members of my family
to celebrate cfar's 40th birthday
the azraeli foundation has been a
supporter of seafarer for many years
and i would say in many ways
seafarers
cfar is one of the organization that
aligns best with our own approach
we really admire how cfar brings
together
the world's best scholars and
researchers to address
high-risk
complex and important questions and we
too believe in its mission which is
indeed nothing less than to overcome the
impossible
now i also remember talking with alan
over lunch which we do a few times a
year probably about 10 years ago
actually
um and it was we talked about our shared
belief that the most important
challenges
in science and education
in health in communities in society
often lie at the boundaries between
fields
now we are strong believers in
multi-disciplinary and collaborative
initiatives
and i guess nothing probably speaks more
to my affinity
for that than that i actually agreed to
moderate this panel
of exceptionally brilliant and
exceptionally different
researchers who are all engaging
in big bold and seemingly impossible
questions
so i'm happy now to welcome our guests
our panelists and i'm going to introduce
you all we have
kyung young cho
i think who is joining us virtually and
who i thought i was supposed to be able
to see
but i might not be able to see him i'm
just going to check before
so i can ensure that he's actually on
there you are
there you are wonderful welcome
is an associate professor at new york
university a cfar fellow in um
cfar's learning and machines and brains
program
as well as i am very proud to say a
member of the 2017-29
cohort of the cfar israeli global
scholars
pyongyang wants to build an intelligent
machine one that communicates with
humans actively seeks knowledge and
creates new knowledge and he and his
collaborators have extensively
investigated natural language processing
and machine translation advancing
research and industrial production of
better machine translation systems
next we have leah cowan down at the end
here
who is a professor and vice president
research
innovation and strategic initiatives at
the university of toronto
leia is the
program co-director of seafarers fungal
kingdom threats and opportunities
program
often called a dynamo i don't know if
you've ever heard that about yourself
leia's laboratory takes on
interdisciplinary approach
to understand what allows some microbes
to exploit exploit the host and cause
disease and to develop new strategies to
treat life-threatening infectious
diseases
she is also the co-founder and chief
scientist i believe chief science
officer
of a new company called bright angel
therapeutics so has this perspective
from both academia and industry i think
has will have some great insight for us
we have amit
morgeria i hope i said that right
morjovia yes is an associate professor
at the kellogg school of management at
northwestern university
and again very proud to say
2021 to 2023 so currently a c far as
really global scholar in the innovation
equity in the future
sorry innovation equity and the future
of prosperity program
amit's research interests are in
economic development
and political economy across several
countries in sub-saharan africa
and among other things he looks at the
political economy of resource management
and nation building
in weak institutionalized and imperfect
democracies so we have real social
scientists on our panel
joel pino just to my left here
is an advisor in cfar's learning in
machines and brains program and is a
canada cfar ai chair at mila which as
alan just mentioned
is one of the three national ai
institutes established through the pan
canadian strategy
joelle is an associate professor at
mcgill where she co-directs the
reasoning and learning lab
and she also leads meta's ai research
lab in montreal
joelle's research focuses on developing
new models and algorithms for planning
and learning in complex and only
partially observable domains and she
applies these algorithms to complex
problems in healthcare in robotics
gaming and conversational agents
and then finally we have on the screen
just above me here
stephanie simmons who is an associate
professor at simon fraser university and
a cfar fellow in the quantum information
science program
stephanie is the founder and chief
quantum officer first time i've heard
that title at photonic inc
she is a world leading expert in
quantum technologies and quantum optics
and she aims to produce a network of
quantum computers able to solve
difficult problems
far beyond the capability of today's
super computers and which we know uh
well
it is surmised that certain kinds of
applications for certain kinds of
applications quantum computing will be
opening the possibility for new means of
for example drug discovery
new sustainable materials and
communicating more securely
stephanie
also has i learned an interest in
building up innovation in canada
and i highly recommend her youtube video
called
canada at the cutting edge of innovation
which is the first time that i kind of
understood something about what quantum
computing was all about so stephanie
thank you for that
um so
as you see from the fungal kingdom and
infectious disease to ai to social
science and economic development to
quantum computing i think you can see
what i meant about
me needing to have the courage of my
convictions
regarding the importance of
interdisciplinarity
to take on this panel but it is a truly
impressive panel
and a testament to seafarer's reach and
the caliber of seafarers outstanding
research community so welcome to all of
you and
let's get started
so my first question uh builds on
the title of today's panel which is
believe the impossible
so we'll just go around and my question
for you is what have you seen in your
field
that seemed impossible when you started
your careers
but is now actually real
so we'll start with you joelle
i have to say there are many many things
that seemed completely impossible to me
the young researcher who started i
i
had no idea the trajectory that ai
research would take over 20 years i i
got into the field out of pure curiosity
in the early days the desire to see that
a robot could move and that some program
that i could design would make this
robot move
in focusing on on robotics uh for a
minute i think some of the most
impressive achievements we've seen in
the last few years is the ability for
robots to navigate terrain and to
navigate some complex manipulation of
their own bodies
and the environment we've seen robots
that can solve rubik's cube with a hand
that is both the program in the
mechanics of it we've seen robots that
climb stairs that navigate terrain and
we're starting to see autonomous
vehicles navigate in crowded city
conditions
all of that required amazing innovation
from the sensor side building the you
know the systems to capture the
information it required incredible
innovation in the algorithm side so the
ability to treat that information
and then it required innovation on the
control side the ability to take out the
actions
on the robot side so it's been
fascinating to see we are by no means
done
um but really that journey over 20 years
has been incredible
amazing
amit
what is it possible now that you
couldn't have imagined well firstly
thank you everyone for being here and
for this opportunity as naomi mentioned
i'm a development economist so typically
development economists have been working
on
improving the lives of the poor and that
usually meant investing in health and
education
however of course people don't sit in a
vacuum they interact with markets and
institutions there's been a lot of work
on understanding institutions so
political economy the state
however more and more in the last 20
years we have seen
putting the microscope on firms and
markets
and that was typically not possible
before because
data wasn't being collected and so what
we have seen in the last 15 20 years is
sort of the courage to go out in the
field and collect bespoke uh design
questionnaires and surveys to collect
data of people uh who you usually do not
see in the data set and so connecting
markets understanding firms has been
sort of a big innovation now uh so i
would put that up there as a as a big uh
sort of progress in understanding the
lives of the poor um
thank you
leia
fantastic thank you so i think you know
a point an example for today would be
the impossible was the idea that the
fungal kingdom would be a cfar program
i think i mean that's amazing these
organisms are you know tremendously
important but often overlooked i think
most people have no idea
what we're talking about when we talk
about fungal kingdom but in fact these
organisms are pervasive and having such
a profound impact on our planet and they
are really interesting because they
really encapsulate the fact that there's
no good and evil in biology these
organisms do so many good things i think
you saw in the video right they can
degrade plastics they can transform
pollution into biofuels they make
medicines like the very first antibiotic
as well as medicines that lower
cholesterol and do other great things
but they also pose devastating threats
so fungi kill over 1.5 million people
every year they are the greatest threat
to food security on the planet
and they're also the only organisms
causing extinctions in real time so they
have such a huge impact but it's been
tremendously difficult to get global
attention on these organisms so sort of
kudos to cfar for having the courage to
support the fungal kingdom and i think
the kinds of discoveries we've seen when
we bring together pediatricians
infectious disease doctors with wildlife
biologists who are discovering vaccines
that can cure bats from devastating
infections is just you know
unprecedented and really remarkable so i
think that's the example i will give for
tonight
thank you
uh
yes um in 2015 i was in a conference
natural language conference processing
conference in beijing
and i was having uh you know beer with
phil blanson and that griffin's that who
are now part of the korea ai in toronto
and what we were
talking about was the test what we you
know jokingly referred to as a chill
test and that is that the within a few
years we're going to have a machine
learning algorithm or the natural
language processing algorithm that's
going to have a
capability to converse with us and
eventually tell us not to hit control c
because that's going to kill it
and then recently during the past few
months i've been following up with all
those that say
amazing outcomes coming out of the big
large-scale
language models that are able to make
conversation with the people
and then that actually does uh seemed
very uh that did seem very impossible in
or you know already in 2015 and somehow
we're getting to a point where this
unity jokingly uh named joe test is
about to be broken or not dissatisfied
but then of course yeah what i want to
say is that the it seems like this kind
of story tells us that our scientific
imagination and ambition are just not
large enough
and in fact the cfr's history of
research support tells us that we must
kind of think beyond our imagination in
order to move forward much more so than
we could imagine
so you know like the i think about this
question i'm almost worried that the our
lack of imagination or the limited
imagination in our field that is deep
learning in my case
may be limiting a factor for us to have
interesting answers to this question in
the future so somehow i'm ending it with
a very uh negative tone but yes that's
the story that i wanted to share with
you
well maybe to put a positive spin on it
it's if you want to predict the future
you have to first create it
that is true and we are learning how to
do that interesting spin on
uh
it's only impossible until it's not
right
uh
i'll turn to you stephanie
thank you so yes i'm i'm trying to build
a quantum computer it is also 40 years
old actually the invention the concept
is about 40 years old and it seemed
impossible for basically the most of the
past 40 years that we would actually
ever build one
it's just the engineering challenge is
needed we knew how we knew what could be
done what what had to be done but the
engineering to meet that aim is
definitely seemed impossible and i would
say that it's it is now realistic it's
not real yet it's still realistic
we've not yet built something at scale
but i would say what has become
what we thought would be would take
hundreds of years to go through the next
phase of commercialization of physics
right like if you go and look at human
history and the technological
developments that have given rise to
entire shifts in the way that we think
they've all been predicated on
commercializing branches of physics
right so
commercializing electromagnetism now
it's something you plug into a wall i
would argue even ai is one of the
um latest stages of the
commercialization of the branch of
semiconductor physics having all this
compute powers enabled this right so we
i didn't think that it would be possible
for us to go through the
commercialization of yet another branch
of physics in my lifetime i thought that
would take you know another couple
decades but um no it really looks like
it's coming online in the in the near
future so it's very exciting um but you
haven't seen anything yet
i'd say
that's fascinating so for you the
impossible was taking something purely
theoretical and making it actually
possible it's commercializing physics
it's interesting absolutely and it's
it's happened at a shocking pace at a
shocking pace like when people when i
went into this i didn't think it would
be really quite i don't think it would
be possible in my lifetime they're just
such um
enormous mountains to climb but that it
has been through the dedicated
fearlessness of so many top researchers
that have
really pecked away at it and made it
very what very much within reach it's
very much in our in our
near-term sites now
so i started off with a question looking
backwards what seemed impossible that's
now possible and now i'm going to ask
you as researchers and scientists
what excites you the most about where
the world is going so if you wanted to
put it another way what do you think is
the next impossible thing the world
might do
i'm just going to mix it up a little bit
let's go ahead leah
so the next impossible i'll consult the
crystal ball
i think
i think it's almost hard to predict
right i think the power is bringing
together these unparalleled great minds
and i think also you know as with the
israeli global scholars it's bringing in
new people right and it's that you know
magic that chemistry that happens by
bringing together these new communities
so i think you know building on some of
the other conversations it's the
exciting
capacity to really catalyze the full
continuum of research so going from
fundamental discovery based science and
we saw that as alan mentioned with the
you know remarkable and transformative
development of vaccines in unparalleled
time span where it was based on hundreds
of people working over 30 years to
develop these really critical
technologies that were all curiosity-led
right this was fundamental science but
being able to bring together the right
people to mobilize communities with a
common mission and to provide funding to
really accelerate discovery that allows
one to go from this fundamental
discoveries right all the way through to
the sort of various stages of
commercialization innovation i'll watch
stephanie's youtube video later right
all the way to you know starting
companies and translating those whether
to have a profound impact so i think for
me the biggest excitement is bringing
together communities to mobilize the
full continuum of research and i think
the sky's the limit for what we can
achieve together
thank you amit i suspect you're going to
have a different type of answer related
to where
um what excites you most about where the
world is going or where is the world
going so what do you think is the next
impossible thing in the world i think my
perspective is uh i i want to take you
all on a quick tour of africa for a
second
so if we take a step back and look at
where
the most people are going to be in the
next 30 years
that's going to be africa so that's one
in four is going to be african
one in three is going to be um a youth
that is also african
what that means is basically that not
only
are you going to have a young population
that's going to demand a lot of jobs
in a continent that doesn't have a lot
of jobs right and so let me put numbers
so we're talking about at the moment 750
million youth in sub-saharan africa
we're going to add another 200 that's
the population of europe we're going to
add another 250 million in the next 28
years
this basically if we round up numbers
sorry i'm going to be uh an economist
for a second we need 20 million new jobs
every year
but we're only creating 3 million jobs
so what's going to happen to the rest
well the rest are going to be restless
they're going to demand uh change
if they because migration is going to be
costly it's risky
and so you're going to have a continent
that is going to change a lot in the
next 28 years which basically means
there's going to be political changes so
the old guards will be waking up
because to claim legitimacy
uh they will need to engage with the
youth
and so part of me is very hopeful we
already see that in sudan you know we're
celebrating the third anniversary of
removing the old gods right in the west
we haven't celebrated that but we're
going to see a lot of protests and riots
taking parts and we're hoping and
optimistically hoping for change and so
we need to be engaging with that
if we don't want to engage with it we'll
be forced to engage with it and so i'm
going to leave it at that
okay
joelle
what would you say
uh
is the next impossible thing
i
one of the
privilege really truly privilege of
being a researcher is instead of you
know trying to predict what is the next
impossible thing
we we get to choose what is the next
impossible thing that we want to work on
and try to solve and quite frankly
listening to my colleagues i'm wondering
whether we should just like switch to
another field i don't know hope it's not
too late
but but i will say something that maybe
reaches some of the ideas they've shared
today
ai
for
60 years or so has been primarily a
discipline of mathematics and
engineering
and yet today ai systems are everywhere
in our lives they are you know embedded
in all of our interactions with the
digital world they're embedded in our
personal relationships and how we build
our communities
and so what i wish for the next several
decades is that we solve that impossible
problem of investing truly human-based
values into the ai systems that we build
and bridging that gap between the kind
of society we want to build and what the
algorithms are doing
and we are starting to see some signs of
that but it's mostly in the language of
the engineering and the mathematical
world
and we need to truly open the doors to
much broader collaborations to to make
some progress on this
that's so interesting so to bring
humanity and
into uh
computational science essentially and
i will say in the small pockets where
we've tried to do this it
it raises some profound questions of
what does it mean what what values do we
want to build into our society how do we
capture that in a language that the
machines
can actually interpret and what are some
of the values that it perpetuates in our
societies so kyung young i know you're
also working on on this type of progress
problem as well would you agree that
that's the next
uh would you wish for that to be the
next big prob uh big
impossible thing
all right dave i really hope that that's
going to the next possible thing that we
can work on to make it possible and
along the line i totally agree with joel
in the sense that
we have as the field of ai we have
actually focused a lot on the problems
that we have a much better handle on
that the problems that we know how to
formulate mathematically we know how to
approach uh from engineering approaches
and so on
and yeah those included many of the
problems that we have seen tremendous
advances in such as say how to play
board games how to build a system that
is able to see objects as well as humans
can do and so on and so on but i guess
you had the next impossible thing just
like what joel pointed out are the
things that we are not even sure how to
you know describe them in succinct way
or the talk about them in a way that is
easily let's say uh communicatable and
so on and yeah along the line uh i i've
enjoyed actually being in this kind of
environment just like joel pointed out
as well especially being part of the
seafarer's early global school learning
idea i got to meet people from cosmology
journalism politics biology neuroscience
and all of those things and
well talking to all those people and
then hearing about the amazing lesson
problems that they're solving that are
still impossible i guess one of the
things that i'll pick one would
be on a more on the biology or the
molecular biology side with the drug
discovery side where we know that
problem exists and then we know the
problem needs to be tackled but then the
thing is when it comes to drug discovery
or any kind of let's say disease it's
not even clear what is the right
mathematical models that we can use to
incorp encapsulate the entire process so
this actually does come back to the
original point that this seems to be one
of those problems that we don't know how
to even approach that easily it seems
like a worthy next impossible thing to
make possible
thank you
and stephanie what would you
what would you say is the
next
what's exciting for you what's coming
next
yeah um in my field in particular i'm
really excited for the imagination of
the kids that are going to grow up
playing with these tools right because
that's where you get true creativity and
we've heard already um
the very voices around the table various
problems that exist um it's it's hard to
articulate just the distinction between
the computational power that we have
versus what's coming um it's really it's
it's a different um it's a very
different beast you can't even imagine
simulating chemicals and all the
complexity those are quantum mechanical
systems right so if you're thinking
about um just imagination and we've
already spoken to this i don't think we
have the right imagination around the
table but maybe let's go back to an
analogy um when they first made it a
transistor semiconductors they thought
the main
use case was a hearing aid a hearing aid
they didn't think of facebook or any of
that they thought of a hearing aid right
so
just take that forward spin that forward
60 years and think about the
imaginations of all the different
interfaces that we have with all the
other disciplines that could bring these
new computational tools to all of their
problems i mean i completely agree it's
the interfaces that are going to unlock
a lot of this
um like room temperature superconductors
if we could actually design that and
that's a like that is a chemistry
simulation problem problems we could
design that what is that going to do for
um getting energy into africa right like
what are we thinking when are we talking
about something big
we don't yet have the tools to fully
simulate the physics of consciousness
just wait until we do you know so
there's there's big things that are
coming in 10 20 40 years i mean i'm
gonna be continually surprised because
people are uh we have the space to be
inventive and now we know how important
it is right we have i think as a as a
culture we prioritize it so there's a
lot to come and i'm just gonna be along
for the ride in some sense trying to
unlock as many doors as we can
so when you mention simulating the
physics of consciousness and joel you
mentioned sort of some troubling
questions that were raised also by
trying to bring human
ethics i'm not because i don't quite
know the words you use but i think you
said human values the words used into
the algorithms
it leads me to a question
almost the flip side of what excites you
to what would you be most concerned
about
um coming up now
i i i i i it's it's hard to to put the
top list i don't know if it's the top
one but i think one thing that i'm
very
um
focused on and concerned about is is
really um
when we do this research when we build
these system when we solve these
problems even when we sit around having
a conversation about what problems we
should be solving the thing that's top
of mind for me is the question of
the representation at the table who is
at the table asking those questions who
is at the table solving those problems
and thinking of how we should do that um
unfortunately
certainly in my field i suspect and
others also we we don't have at the
table all of the representation that we
should um
and and so you know issues of bringing
much more people from underrepresented
groups
to the scientific fields to participate
in programs to have access to top
quality education
is really top of mind for me because i
think unless we do that we're not going
to unleash the full potential of
research
thank you amit what would you say is
your main concern looking ahead to the
future
i think i go back to
my subject of interest which is
development in africa and when we think
about um
where is those
opportunities for job creation
to absorb the youth
it's going to come
from agriculture doing agriculture
better agriculture that connects to
global markets
now most of the time we have very little
information um
at the supply chain level because we
know the formal firms but the formal
firms are interlinked to the rural poor
uh and we have to engage with that uh
and so those are the challenges of
engaging with them understanding their
lives which we need to overcome if we
want to bring innovation prosperity uh
in those environments which is the
program i'm part of the iep so i think
more and more engaging with where the
problem starts in measuring that problem
putting a magnitude to it
that's how you can come up with a
solution or potential set of solutions
thank you
leia from your perspective
it's hard to say because there's so many
challenges right i think humanity is
facing so many
and there's
so many that are important and they
influence each other so you can't pick
one
it's hard to pick one that's why i'm
glad there's so many cfar programs and
that's one of the reasons also that i
engage with my particular job of running
research and innovation for the
university and thinking about ways to
support not just my own program but lots
and lots of other research programs i
think it's hard to argue that climate
change is not going to be one of the
biggest challenges facing humanity uh
that's not my direct area so i'm
thrilled to be able to support other
scholars that are addressing this
head-on but i also know these problems
are all interconnected so we think about
climate change and of course i'll take
us to the fungal kingdom
but we we know that
as we select for different temperatures
around the world we're selecting for
organisms that survive at higher
temperatures and our high body
temperature has many functions but one
of which is to thwart off infectious
disease which is why we have fevers
right to help clear off infection and in
fact as there's warmer climates we're
seeing that there's an increase in fungi
and other organisms that can survive at
higher temperatures which has tremendous
implications for thinking about the
spread of infectious disease and we've
seen how all kinds of modern innovations
like travel and all modern medicine all
kinds of things that we do to change our
own living experience
have created more opportunities for
infectious disease to emerge and spread
worldwide we've seen that very clearly
in recent years and i think it's pretty
clear we can expect more of that so
many challenges and lots of
interconnections between them so climate
change
leading to i think it's called zonosis
the
jumping from
animals to
to humans in terms of infection and also
melting ice and
that might release is that people talk
about that is that yeah there's many we
could have a long discussion
which we probably won't have time for in
this particular forum but there's many
opportunities i mean i think human
interaction with animals in all sorts of
different contexts and consumption is a
huge impact in terms of zoonoses and
acquisition of infections from animals
but the other piece is just with higher
temperatures organisms adapt right
evolution happens so these microbes are
evolving the ability to survive at
higher temperatures and as such they can
overcome our sort of human thermal
barrier that helps protect us from
infections so we become more vulnerable
as the world warms and we're seeing that
in real time
it's fascinating we think about climate
change and rising water levels but not
as much about climate change and
infection
stephanie what would you what would you
say would be of greatest concern what
you know
i think if anything um just to kind of
echo some of the points that were
already made and maybe build upon them i
think if anything the thing i'm most
concerned about is a lack of human
adaptability and lack of evidence-based
action because there's a lot of change
there's a lot of change and like i have
a whole laundry list of quantum stuff
that you guys don't even know about
that's coming too right so there's
there's all this stuff that's coming
and uh i think if we keep our cool and
we keep our heads on our shoulders and
we we remain adaptable we are an
adaptable species but like double down
on adaptability and evidence-based
action uh then we there is a way out on
all of these things right it's about
actually navigating um
with uh
with grace and if we can do that then
i'm not as concerned but my concern is
that we won't have
we will keep cool under pressure
yes i don't sometimes when you look at
the world over the last uh 24 36 months
and you wonder if adapting with grace is
really one of our great strengths as a
species
but we have adapted uh
uh
where would you say what would you say
is your main concern about what's coming
um
so
recently during the past let's say a
couple of years the ai has brought a lot
of the excitement uh you know rightly so
there's been a lot of to say scientific
offenses that
you know like they showed us things that
we thought were impossible were indeed
possible and you know i did that's the
right thing for the whole society to be
you know be excited by all these
scientific advances and that's probably
the reason why many of us here are
scientists ourselves but then the one
thing that i see as increasingly missing
from many of these conversations even
among the scientists
is the fact that we cannot only be
excited by the scientific advances but
also we have to be quite skeptical about
the a lot of scientific outcomes that
are being published as well as to
discuss
and unfortunately i don't think the
society or the whole let's say
institutions educational institutions we
are training our next generation
scientists to be both excited by the
advances and also be skeptical about
them and along this line i think one of
the things that concerns me most when i
talk with the scientists as well as
engineers and the idea everyone else in
the society is that
i think we be due to the uh incentive
structure of the whole society that
actually does put a lot of emphasis on
the immediate incentives i don't i don't
think we're doing a good job of training
ourselves or the uh you know training
ourselves to imagine
of any any kind of scientific advances
we tend to see the immediate
consequences they are too positive often
and we don't really tend to spend enough
efforts or time trying to think about a
long term potentially negative
consequences of the different let's say
algorithms that we introduce or the
different lesson findings that we bring
into the world so yeah so my major
concern is this lack of imagining
long-term negative consequences or the
lack of the training to do so
so i'm going to link what you just said
jungyeon to what something joel said and
i wonder if there was greater
representation in science whether we
would be able we would be training
differently and possibly be able to
anticipate some of those long-term
consequences could you maybe speak to
that about what it would mean to bring
more diversity into just the actual
the act of the research and how that
might change how the questions are even
posed
i strongly believe this i strongly
believe that we we need to have that
conversation with a broader set of
people i think that's what it comes down
to me but
but but research is also the you know it
takes a lot of time in terms of the
trajectory the learning trajectory to
get to the point i i sometimes say
to the to the young students in my lab
you know asking the right question is
the hardest thing
in in that you need to have that nugget
of a hypothesis of a question that's
worth solving but that you have a chance
to solve and you have a particular
unique insight that means that even
though people have tried before that you
actually have an end goal that you will
you will be able to do it and so it
takes all of that training for to
develop researchers and so it means we
have to to look early on in terms of
establishing the opportunities for for
learning and for education
for more people to have be able to
participate and then perhaps to kyung
young's point we might actually
be better at
uh imagining outcomes as well
i sure hope so i sure hope so
so i'm conscious of the time but i'm
going to ask one further question i'm
going to now shift
the focus to the theme of collaboration
which we've all talked about in various
ways it has you know occurred to me that
the five of you
um really would have interesting
insights into the question of
collaboration its place in research and
in particular in innovation and also
from different perspectives because
while you all have academic backgrounds
academic positions
um
leia for example you're looking at it
also from the administrative standpoint
as well as
from founding a company um and joelle
and stephanie have both co-founded
companies so it's also looking at the
perspective
of collaboration and innovation in
industry versus in academic spaces so i
think that there's there's something to
unpack there perhaps you could share
your insights about collaboration in
research from your
different perspectives is there actually
such a thing as a culture of
collaboration and
how and why and under what circumstances
does collaboration actually make a
difference to discovery and i'll start
with you stephanie
put you on the spot oh sure am i almost
gonna be a little bit more contrarian
but i was going to say that actually um
part of the part of the best part of
collaboration is when
not everyone agrees
actually you can get a lot done when
when um you can support minority voices
and you have that space to have that
minority voice and do the thing that's
on the edge and look at things that
nobody else has looked at and you get
the kind of feedback loop from other
people who see the space but i think
there's um
one of the things that makes cfar as
beautiful as it is is that it at least
from what i've seen in the programs i've
seen it does really support those kinds
of contrarian opportunities like the
challenges the risk-taking to go out on
the edge and and yeah if it doesn't work
then it doesn't work but you learn
something along the way and most of the
time it does most of the time if you
point smart people in a good way they
find out something but i was going to
suggest that one of the
most lovely things about collaboration
is is the opportunity to support each
other as we go off and do slightly uh
edge edge case work and really push the
boundaries not necessarily all together
but just to help each other all the way
pushing boundaries um in our own
direction simultaneously so
maybe would you say
would you say that those opportunities
are the same in industry or in academic
spaces no no no so not at all um
i think
there's there's a very different flavor
for it um both of them have their own
versions of groupthink
let's say
but they definitely have very different
flavors um i can elaborate if you like
but i might as well pass the baton
well perhaps we'll come back to that leo
from your perspective both in industry
an academic researcher and also
administrator within
uh the ecosystem of supporting research
what's your perspective on the way
collab how collaboration happens now and
it's
its place and how it might be different
in different
environments
yeah so collaboration i think is
absolutely fundamental to almost
everything that we do because so few big
grand challenges can be solved with a
single mind a single approach a single
expertise right so i think
most and much of this at least the
science area that i work in
we always bring diverse people to the
table we need people who are leading an
ai to come help us solve all kinds of
problems we need people who are thinking
about chemistry and developing new
molecules we need people who are
thinking about infectious disease and
treating patients we need all of these
kinds of people who develop new
technologies solve structures of targets
so
collaboration is fundamental i think to
solving big challenges how you create a
culture and an ecosystem of
collaboration is a is an important piece
and that culture is different in
different environments but certainly you
have to have spaces that are safe for
different perspectives i think as
stephanie alluded to that
you know conflict is part of finding a
path right and you have to have spaces
to explore that
there's also all kinds of challenges
when you collaborate across institutions
right so making sure there's ways to
safely share data making sure there's
clear understanding about
openness of data
sharing there's all kinds of questions
that need to be worked through very
thoughtfully through clear communication
and appropriate agreements in advance
and i think stephanie alluded to the
culture being different in academia and
industry and i think there's also
different cultures and different kinds
of industries there's not one model
neither is there one model for academic
research environments but certainly
collaborative spaces accelerate
discovery
so i think it's worth the effort of
making sure one develops a culture that
supports that
so both land stephanie have alluded to
how conflict is part of the
collaborative process i wonder amit if
you could talk about
conflict within attempts to collaborate
in your area and in economic development
and social sciences because perhaps
sometimes their conflict and not in is
can be more of an obstacle than it is
part of the collaborative process
thanks yeah so uh economics is not a
team sport
it's changing now uh we are you will see
much more multiple participants in a
project as we take on more complex
problems but i'll flip the question and
sort of focus on the collaboration with
government and the private sector which
is where most of my work is it's
observing markets and now as an academic
you come in with a certain perspective
and you expect markets to function in a
certain way but when you realize on the
ground that they do have a deep
understanding of markets but there are
other constraints that
are at play that you might not be
thinking about and so you study might
find a particular result in a particular
policy
and you need to engage with the
government now because they're expecting
some results from you they have helped
to fund support your study
but the policy recommendations are
sometimes even orthogonal to what the
current political climate is and that's
going back to my esteemed colleagues
conversation now that has taken place
that you have to build a safe space a
space of trust
uh and also empower them because at the
end of the day
development problems the participants
need to own the problem and you are part
of the solution you're not the solution
and so that engagement takes time um
repeated interaction
uh as well as being a good listener i
think that's one of the things i've
learned you might have your own ideas uh
but to listen to new ideas and changing
um
your approach is is very important so
being agile
is also key
yeah thank you so um kyung young and
joelle to to take it from the
perspective of ai now and collaboration
clearly the entire field is
the product of collaboration on on the
edges between between different
approaches
and coming back to this question of
culture of collaboration
where does it fit in with ai and with
[Music]
where you think
the next discoveries might be also in
artificial intelligence which we've
touched on already but but
you know competition can also spark
the
the um this these types of discovery um
where does that fit in the field of ai
maybe at kyung young why don't you begin
ah okay
that is a very uh heavy question
so one thing i want to say is that since
you know seafarer is a safe place so you
know i'm going to say something
contrarian a bit here because i thought
it was encouraged in order to
collaborate
um
i feel like it's neither the competition
nor the collaboration in my view uh in a
sense that the i think one of the
biggest let's say
hurdles to the advances in ai as well as
the any kind of say collaborative effort
in science is the i think the individual
researchers are emotional attachment to
the ideas that may or may not be true
because the kind of emotional attachment
that i've seen a lot in many different
uh in ai as well as the other fields is
that they tend to
lead people to be quite defensive of
their own listed ideas or their own
findings regardless of whether they are
going to eventually end up as even true
or not and that actually does lead to
lack of conversation across the
different spectrum of people and also
creates a kind of let's say bubbles of
the different ideas that do not talk
with each other
and so i feel like i do one of the
things that uh you know for ai as well
as the other fields to move forward in a
much grander sense is for individual
scientists to kind of say start dropping
some of this emotional attachment and
then your idea is let me point it out uh
trying to be as agile as possible and
then trying to you know be a part of a
much bigger conversation without having
to having to feel that you know i own a
certain part or the i own and majority
of the part
and perhaps the
ai or many of these automated algorithms
might be uh might have some let's say
ways to help people in your idea
detaching themselves from the individual
ideas and be able to feel much more
involved in the entire community's uh
joint efforts
thank you joelle
collaboration yeah let me add
one element that i think is is important
which is in any good collaboration it's
great for each
person contributing to bring a special
value to the to the work that we do
together and so we've had a lot of work
across um academia and industry in ai in
particular over the last few years
several researchers with with a foot in
in each um
in in that it's important to to keep in
mind you know what type of work is best
suited to what type of environment we do
see a lot of universities taking on much
more creating higher risk work
often quite honestly the best ideas also
come from the younger generations of
researchers and so having that ability
to to work across both has been
wonderful on the university side there's
immense creativity you know there's a
there's a courage that comes from
from
from the young researchers that is
wonderful on the industry side there's
an ability once we have a promising
enough hypothesis and enough probing
evidence to just go all in invest you
know we've seen a lot of work on
can you mention it earlier on large
language models training these very
large models that require large gpu
infrastructure and so this is something
that industry does quite well
one ingredient we've seen that allows
that collaboration to go well is when
there's a joint commitment to open
science and this is something that nai
has been quite interesting that we've
been able to have several industry
research lab commit to an open science
model in some cases being careful around
data sharing of course which has some
particularity but on the ideas on the
software and so on a large movement
towards open sourcing towards sharing
the results openly which i think is
really um improving the speed of
innovation and this is the reason that
the industry commits to it is really to
contribute to that speed of innovation
that's that's fascinating and uh
um i think the the approach of open
science in almost any field um
can really be seen as a catalyst to real
forward absolutely yes
so uh i'm conscious of the timer we're
going to wrap up i think i'll just ask
if you like to share any last thoughts
with uh with the audience here on
anything i think we've all really
enjoyed hearing from you and your
different perspectives don't be shy jump
in if there's something you wanted to
say that you didn't have a chance to
leia yeah i would just say a big thank
you to cfar i mean this is such an honor
and a privilege to be part of the cfar
family the support that we've had from
our program directors our research
directors who've been amazing from the
knowledge mobilization teams you know
just amazing the communication the
public talks have been amazing those
have been great to participate in and to
see family and friends chiming in and
learning about what's happening in the
cfar sphere and learning so much and
being engaged in these conversations so
i think huge thank you to cfar and also
thank you to the israeli global scholars
because this opportunity to bring in
sort of the next generation allows us to
do so much more it's so catalytic and
completely transformative for the
careers of these folks who are then
going to be the next generation of
leaders so my remarks are just to thank
you thank you
i was i was actually going to go in the
same direction i think you know some of
us have the privilege to travel the
world and meet researchers from around
the world and honestly i think what
seafarer has created is absolutely
unique and and for people who may not
have that opportunity
both the the diversity of ideas and
people who are coming together on these
particular programs is something we
don't find
anywhere else and so i think we should
be really proud of what cfar has built
over 40 years
and as a researcher i'm deeply thankful
for what what has been created here
thank you thank you
i'll see
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll add on to that first uh thanking
cifer at the global scholars program for
giving me the opportunity a development
economist had a seat at the table on a
program that's about innovation mainly
in the rich countries and so i really
appreciate that that opinion option as
well as an africanist um that's that's a
real privilege and honor and the second
i would like to remind you that please
visit africa uh africa is huge you know
it's larger than putting the us india
china western europe japan so it's a
large large continent but
visit the east africa that's where i'm
from uh look at the markets look at the
dynamism and invest there right that's
uh that's what i'll end with wonderful
wonderful
or stephanie would you like to add
anything yeah i can go first again my
first deep dive into deep learning was
ipam summer school sponsored by cfar in
july 2012 that was exactly 10 years ago
and since then i've been supported by
cfr via various programs including the
israeli global scholar
and uhd i and that's been tremendously
helpful for my career as well as for me
to be able to contribute contribute back
to the research community and i hope to
be able to contribute back even further
to cfar as well as the research
community in the next 10 years thank you
thank you
last word to you stephanie yeah thank
you i would just say the only reason
that i'm in quantum information science
is because some of the early quantum
information work was done at sea far
away when i was very very young and so
there's there's a lot of history here
that you know 40 years that's that's
phenomenal it was way ahead of its time
and it's still ahead of its time and
there's 40 years to come where it's
still going to be defining the future
and so it's not just thank you for this
moment in time but it's also thank you
for the history that brought us to where
we are and and thank you for everything
that's to come it's such a phenomenal
organization thank you
thank you and and thank you all
you know i think it's very clear um that
the world's very best researchers share
a common goal they have a passion for
advancing our knowledge our knowledge of
the world
and in doing so to make the world a
better place
um alan actually once said that
exceptionally talented researchers shine
like a bright light in a dark sky i
don't know if you remember that you said
that but you said that
so i would say to all of us gathered
here that our guests today are clearly
these bright lights
um and i know that you join me in
thanking them uh it has been such an
insightful discussion so thank you to
the five of you
and i know also that c4 cfar's future is
bright so here's to the next 40 years
and i'm looking forward to seeing what
they will bring so thank you very much
it's been a pleasure
[Applause]
now you know i have the best job in
sciences probably in the world
and for the board members if our board
members i've withdrawn my resignation by
the way
um
like i want to thank you first of all
naomi for doing a super job of
moderating
although i don't think they needed you
they could just
go
but thank you very much and to joelle i
meet leah and uh they're they're gone
maybe they can still hear me kyung young
and steph uh super job really
um and we didn't
[Applause]
uh inspiring and um
uh just wonderful
um the reason i have the best job in
science is there's five of them
i have 395 other fellows advisors and
scholars
as good as these guys
uh out there and so i've been like a kid
in a candy shop for the last 10 years
it's now my pleasure to
in terms of closing these uh wonderful
uh hour or so introduce um ann mcclellan
uh anne is uh the honorable anne
mcclellan uh and is a seaforth's uh uh
vice chair uh she served as a member of
parliament with great distinction over
four terms
she served probably in every position in
the cabinet over that time minister of
justice i know she was minister of
health because i was president of cihr
when she was the minister of health
um she was a deputy prime minister under
prime minister martin and also the
minister for national security
public safety same thing
and i've been arguing for a long time
over everything
so uh and she serves on seafarers board
with with truly great distinction and
thank you
do i need that
people usually don't have trouble
hearing me so
anyway thank you very much alan i'm here
on behalf of our board chair bill young
uh bill couldn't be with us today so
bill asked me to just step in and say a
big thank you in closing and pauline and
leslie gave me one minute
so this will be heartfelt but short
uh but uh first let me say that actually
at uh cfar we have two co-chairs
and i bring greetings from dr uh jaclyn
kerner who is actually teaching a class
right now at simon fraser university
and couldn't be with us but jacqueline
wanted me to extend her sincere best
wishes
to our wonderful speakers but to
everybody here
and as you've heard this is the kickoff
event for our 40th uh anniversary
and there will be more events like this
throughout the year and across the
country and we hope that you and others
will be able to participate and learn
more about what cfar does but what we do
is what all our wonderful speakers
were talking about today and naomi these
wonderful speakers and cfar can only do
what they do and we do because of you
and uh i want to thank you on behalf of
the board thank the azraeli foundation
for everything you do two uh scholars
here today one former one current but i
think we have a sense of how
important your support and the families
and the foundation's support is on
behalf of the whole board a sincere
thank you for your years of support of
cfar and young people who are committed
to in fact uh believing the impossible
and then discovering it wasn't
impossible after all and making the
world a better place
so
with that
again
thank you to our speakers naomi
wonderful job have you thought of
politics
a wonderful job moderating this event
and uh let me say
finally uh there will be many
opportunities in the coming uh weeks
and months to say
thank you alan bernstein but uh we are
going to say thank you dr bernstein this
evening
a remarkable career a remarkable human
being he is absolutely right i met him
when i was minister of health i'd been
on the job one day
and you
you walk through the door and say i must
see the minister of health because he
thought his funding was in jeopardy or
something right
anyway all that to say that i've had the
honor of knowing dr bernstein for these
past 20 or more years many of you in
this room have known him for much longer
but his contributions to science are
remarkable but as a former politician
let me say alan
his contribution to better public policy
in this country is the thing that i
think we should all be thanking him for
and helping successive governments
understand the importance of the place
of science in good public policy thank
you alan
so
please hang around hang around i think
the reception is continuing right
pauline so please stay and get to chat
informally with our wonderful speakers
with naomi with the israeli family and i
hope you take a look at this amazing
artist over here who is taking some all
these ideas that she heard today i think
and right and putting them together uh
in that form so please go by and say
hello and see uh the themes that she
took from what she heard today so thank
you all enjoy the evening and remember
this is the beginning of our 40th
celebration of seafar thank you
[Applause]